we're heading into November and starting
big with call of duty infinite warfare
take up the cause for the United Nations
space alliance as captain Nick Reyes and
lead your team of special operatives on
a mission to stop the warmongering
settlement Defense front forces from
destroying the earth zombie mode Returns
set in an 80s movie theme park where for
inspiring actors fight off an endless
wave of zombies special guest David
Hasselhoff I know right joins you in a
zombie killing rampage what's not to
love about that you start taking down
space marines and 80 zombies on the
fourth in space yep we're in space bust
out that tailored suit tie up that red
tie you've got one more contract to
fulfill in hit man's final episode of
season one writing to a five-star resort
and the snowy mountains of Japan's
Hokkaido region to investigate a dark
secret your mission if you choose to
accept it agent is to take out your old
boss Eric soldiers for good go in
stealthy or guns blazing it's your
choice take on your final mission on the
31st you can spread those wings and fly
away yourself an owl boy you play Otis a
member of the owl human hybrid race who
along with friends must venture forth
below the clouds to fight a horde of
pirates monsters and more defend your
home and find clues as to what is really
going on down there take to the skies on
the first
have you ever dreamed of running your
own football league gathering the talent
constructing the formations making
trades you can do it all in football
manager 2017 the game offers you a
variety of clubs to choose from or make
your own to start your managing career
you can even customize the look of your
manager to get an in-depth player to
player stats as your team soars through
the league to become champions lead your
team to victory on the fourth it's that
time of year again will we gather the
family around for a turkey dinner yay so
why not liven things up with mario party
star rush instead of the turn-based
mario party we've come to know and love
you're free to move about the map as you
please challenging other players to a
wide variety of minigames set up the
board and get ready to roll those dice
the party begins on the 4th and that's
all the time I have today folks I hope
you all have a great weekend and a happy
Halloween scaring the pants off of
people remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
you